hi there Steve Kaufman here again um
today I want to talk about words it's a
subject that comes up all the time how
many words do we need to know and of
course I have I guess two quick answers
to that the first answer is lots lots of
words and the second answer is what do
you want to do with the language so some
of you may know that at Linc we count
the number of known words of each
learner and I happen to believe that the
number of known words is the simplest
indicator of your level in the language
if you're looking for one simple Gordian
knot Occam's razor indicator of where
you stand in the language it's the
number of words you know so now let me
explain a little further on that I of
course there are uncertainties for
example the number of known words in a
very inflected language is going to be
more than language that's not inflected
by inflected I mean a language where the
words change form for person tense you
know function in the sentence and so
forth and so on
so typically 70,000 words in Russian may
equate to 15,000 words in English I
don't know what the conversion rate is
so that the number of known words say
that we indicate at link it's not an
absolute number it can't be compared
from language to language that just just
the principle is that the more words you
know in the language the further along
you are the better you know the language
people will object they'll say well when
do you how do you know if you know a
word and my definition is I know it when
I can understand it in a context that's
all because the goal for me is first of
all to
stand the language because if my goal is
fluency I have to be able to understand
many different contexts I want to
understand books when I read them I want
to understand people when they speak and
native speakers will always have a much
bigger vocabulary than I have as a
learner not always but in most cases and
so I have to understand what they're
saying otherwise I can't communicate
with them now if my goal is simply to be
able to order food in a restaurant order
a beer find my way to the bathroom say
hi how are you have a good weekend if
that's the limit of what I want to
achieve in the language which is
perfectly legitimate then you know fair
to say I don't need so many words but my
goal in language learning is to be able
to participate in intelligent
conversations read books understand
movies
listen to the radio to the news listen
to audiobooks and for that you need lots
of words whenever I am reading a book
even in the language that I know fairly
well it's the words that prevent me from
understanding so a my goal my simple
goal is simple you know the milestones
on my road towards fluency the
milestones are the number of words that
I know so now this is some people
dispute that this you hear this argument
that well you know the most common
thousand words account for 75 80 percent
of the language so you only have to
learn those words well that's simply not
true if you want to be fluent if you
want to be comfortable discussing a wide
variety of subjects there if those top
1,000 most frequent words will appear
all the time
so if you are doing a lot of listening
and reading in order to increase your
vocabulary you will necessarily go over
these frequent words very often so you
will in fact nail those frequent words
fairly early although you may forget
some of them along the way and it is a
good idea
when you first start to start out for
the first month or two to limit your
reading and listening to content that
has instead of 75% high-frequency words
95% high-frequency words because there
is so much in the language that's
uncertain unknown in order for you to
get a bit of a grip on the language it's
better to have a higher percentage of
words that are easy that you're going to
see so often that they're more likely to
stick for you but very soon in my
experience after a couple of months you
have to move on to a more normal content
not designed for the learner where the
percentage of the lower frequency words
is much higher you have to do that
because otherwise it's you can't find
anything interesting to read or listen
to at least that's been my experience
and in order to learn these words that
are less frequent you have to read and
listen a lot I have not found in my own
case that it's been that helpful to try
to learn words out of context I learn
words within a context even at link when
I review flashcards I much prefer to
review the flashcards that came from a
specific content item so what happens
with this word counter is if you have
accumulated a large number of words even
a passive knowledge of a large number of
words and if you have acquired them
through what I would call honestly
through a lot of listening and reading
then that is kind of a a milestone of
the amount of exposure that you have had
to the language and that means that you
have therefore absorbed so much more of
the language and along the way have
learned other things about the language
like the structure and certainly as I
always say as a part of your you know
listening and reading you do want to
regularly have a look at the grammar but
you need that base of words right now
I'm enjoying a tremendous content a
series a collection that if Guinea has
put into our Russian library called what
is it comedy call it practice kaya ruse
kaya gramatica practical Russian grammar
and but I use a lot of words
the grammar but he explains it and then
he has a lot of examples and so it's
enjoyable so I go and spend a little
time with the grammar listening to Jenny
but I go back and I work on my reading
and my listening and linking of course
to expand my vocabulary because I need a
lot of words so that if I pick up a
newspaper if I turn on the TV if I meet
someone we're discussing any subject
that I'll have a better chance of
understand what their understanding what
they're talking about the fact that your
active vocabulary is always going to be
much smaller is less of a problem you
may struggle you can limit your
participation in the discussion to those
words that you're able to use which will
always be a much smaller part of your
total vocabulary but if you can't
understand what the other person is
saying because you don't know the words
then you won't be able to participate in
the conversation so to me the single
most you know if you needed one sort of
factor one index of how far along you
are in the language it's the number of
words you know and that is what drives
me and my language learning
I want to acquire more and more and more
words so that if I open an item in link
I see maybe five or 10% new words in
blue instead of 30 or 40 or 50 I want to
get those pages whiter and whiter
because that tells me that I'm
understanding more and more and sure
enough if I pick up a book I can read it
and I can understand it and then when
the opportunity arises as David James
says if you have a solid base in terms
of passive vocabulary and lots of
listening and reading when you have the
opportunity to speak and whenever that
opportunity arises at whatever stage
along your path you're going to be able
to take advantage of it and your ability
to produce the language will will you
know develop very very quickly if you
don't have the words then there's not
much point in in sort of practicing what
to say at the train station and what to
say you know at the post office because
you won't understand much of what comes
back
so just a quick assertive summary of of
you know the question is how many words
do you know you need to know well a in
principle lots and B it depends on your
goals if you want to be able to operate
as an intelligent person able to discuss
a variety of subjects without the native
speaker having to slow down repeat
explain it in other words and so forth
then you need a lot of words if you want
to be able to go and have a couple of
drinks and say that the weather is nice
then of course you don't need so many
words so it does depend on your goals
but to my mind the number of words you
know is the quickest indicator of how
far along you are in the language thank
you for listening bye for now